Yes. Ken Mandl, I direct a program at
Boston Children's Hospital called the Computational Health Informatics Program,
where we've got 23 faculty doing work in informatics across multiple dimensions.
One of those dimensions is SMART on FHIR.
Well, at that moment,
the adoption of electronic health records was
only about five percent in both inpatient and outpatient settings.
There was about to be first a 19 billion but
then a $48 billion federal incentive program
and around promoting the adoption of electronic health records.
The opportunity we thought was then
to dictate what the requirements of that program might be.
And we suggested that the requirements could be
reduced to really one very simple principle,
which is that the electronic medical records should be able to behave like iPhones,
and that they should be able to run apps,
and that those apps should be able to be added
to or deleted from the electronic medical record.
We call that the principle of substitutability and argued that
substitutability should be the driving force behind interoperability.
The opportunity was designed to produce a few important effects.
One was so that innovators could readily get their innovations to
the point of care in the same way that
app developers for the iPhone platform were able to do that.
It separated the innovators from
the electronic medical record companies and that
our vision of substitutability was that it would also be vendor independence.
So the app developer wouldn't even need
to know which electronic health record it was going to run on.
Now, the iPhone was only one year old at the time.
And when we wrote the article,
there were 10,000 apps developed for the iPhone.
When it was published three months later,
there were 50,000 apps in the iTunes App Store.
And so we caught this phenomenon at a hockey sticking moment,
and the world was just starting also to understand why
the iPod that they had now needed to make phone calls or,
alternatively, why their telephone needed to play music.
And people were starting to understand this App Store was actually
a really important part of this new technology.
So one is innovator to the point of care.
The other is end users so that they can actually select from
a market of applications as opposed to only what comes out of the box,
such as the end users can enjoy a truly competitive market to
produce the functionality that they want and to enable them to
customize that functionality if they want to produce apps within their organizations.
Yes. It's really, I think, a very happy story.
We began with a restful model of call-in resources across
an API and with
well-defined resources that represent only a subset of all possible types of health data,
the most useful subset to get started with.
And we used an RDF technology initially to define those resources,
and we were actually getting apps developed and developing our own apps.
But we started to see this very interesting FHIR community cohering.
And not only did we think it was interesting,
but we jumped in and decided to actually help create the FHIR standard and
to really promote it and to get behind the founders of FHIR.
Another nice aspect of it for SMART is that wall SMART
was attempting to define a universal standard for an API.
The SMART team had no aspirations to become a standards body.
So the fact that SMART had been ingested into HL7,
and that HL7 was going to not only further develop the standard
but also make it freely available was extremely attractive.
And it became very clear that one way that SMART could have longevity and
scale would be to rely on a standards body for the standards part of the project.
On the whole, the products on the market are
older software stacks that are monolithically designed and many of them are pre-Internet.
Now, they are, of course,
being updated all the time but the degree to which
the developers in the EMR companies could be truly nimble about
evolving the products and somewhat limited by their complexity.
So what SMART enables the ecosystem to produce
is essentially a facade that interoperates with the electronic medical record,
leaving it fully in place,
keep taking advantage of all its myriad capabilities but providing for
the clinician or for the patient a modern web-based user interface.
So what SMART does very specifically is it brings the full capabilities
of the worldwide web to the point of care connected to the electronic medical record.
So, now, you can do anything you can do on the web and
HTML5 with data mashups, data visualizations,
bringing in external data sources,
genomics for example or environmental data,
and do it in the context of the physician workflow.
It's a very good question.
SMART on FHIR apps can begin to play a role in bringing evidence to the point of care.
First of all, I think we're in a transition where we believe
that evidence comes from data at least as much as it comes from the medical literature.
So one way that evidence-based medicine has been
interpreted is the best use of the medical literature as applied to one's patient.
So SMART on FHIR can help with that aspect of
a traditionally defined evidence-based medicine
through its connections into decision support through
this CDS Hooks process or other ways to bring in guidelines
and interpreted medical literature into the decision making process of the physician.
But the other aspect that I think is more exciting even is
that decisions will be made on the basis of
insights that have been derived through advanced modeling and
deep learning or even derived on the fly from very large population data sets.
Interestingly, those data sets are created in part through electronic medical records,
collecting data from every visit.
But, also, data is important from other sources: social media, public health genomics.
And all of those forms of data can provide a new kind of evidence-based medicine,
a really data-driven form of evidence-based care.
And through the power of simply taking advantage
of all the innovations that have happened in the web
and the opportunity to bring data sources together to
have different computational processes interacting with each other,
to provide advanced data visualization,
we can begin to bring this new form of data
driven evidence right into the physician's workflow.
Absolutely. So SMART on FHIR actually is a project that
builds upon work we did around a patient-controlled health record,
in which there is a repository of data that
the patient controls with apps running on top.
The problem with patient-controlled health records in the past has been that they
haven't been easily fed by data from electronic medical records in other systems.
The data hasn't been interoperable.
So, patients haven't been empowered with their data and they
certainly haven't been empowered with apps running on their data.
Instead, what patients got over the last decade or so
was portals that are bolt ons to the electronic medical record.
And so those portals give patients a view into the electronic medical record data.
Generally, they don't take the data out with them,
but at least, they can see it.
The portals, therefore, have had somewhat limited functionality.
The opportunity now that's SMART on FHIR brings to the patient is two-fold.
One, it lets the patient actually take out their data and get a copy of it.
The right to do that is reinforced by what's called meaningful use stage three.
And it's also reinforced by now the 21st Century Cures Act, which is law.
So, the patient can get a copy of their data.
And secondly, the patient can connect apps just like
the provider apps to an electronic medical records system,
so that they can enjoy the same kinds of benefits, data visualization,
data mashups, computational processes,
serving their healthcare needs.
Well, it's very interesting.
There's an absolutely exploding field around data generated by sensors,
data generated by standard mobile devices, iPhones and androids,
and data developed by the same technologies and various wearable forms.
The ability to ingest those data into
the electronic medical record is one important area.
Electronic medical records are not particularly designed to do this,
so one intermediate layer where the data from the electronic medical record
and from this new generation of sensor technologies,
is in this SMART on FHIR layer.
On top of the electronic medical record,
it also provides a real opportunity to
deliver the right interpreted information from these sensors to the clinician.
Most clinicians will not be interested in raw data.
And so, the question that everyone's asking is,
"What's the best set of workflows to get those data
into a decision making process with the physician and the patient?"
I think SMART on FHIR apps provide at least an early solution to addressing that issue.
Well, I think one
of the most exciting opportunities to interface public health to the point of care,
is the tremendous population and representative
population data resources that public health has that can
form the decision making for an individual patient.
A patient's diagnosis, or laboratory data,
or symptoms, not in an epidemiological context,
is much less useful.
So for example, if a patient has a sore throat,
and we're trying to decide whether to test them for Strep,
there is a much higher chance that that test will be
positive if there is Strep going around in that person's area.
That could be readily derived from a population health,
or public health dataset.
That could guide our testing,
and rational testing, and treatment around Strep throat.
Reduction of false positives could save
literally hundreds of thousands of courses of antibiotics per year.
That's one example of how population data can inform individual care.
So it's a very nice research-related use of the SMART API,
such that a participant in the precision medicine initiative,
now known as the All of Us Initiative,
can request a copy of their data from their local health system by connecting
an app to the Smart API at that health system,
and direct a copy of those data to
go to the Precision Medicine Initiative or the All of Us Initiative.
It's essentially a way that operational liases data donation for research subjects in
a very large study seeking to recruit a million patients.
So, I think at the moment,
we have an incredible opportunity with SMART,
because it's been built into the electronic medical record products.
It's essentially been regulated that there be these APIs.
And even beyond regulated,
it's made it into the law.
So we're moving into a more modern era of
interaction and interoperability between medical systems.
Where I think we need a lot of emphasis now is to create a robust apps ecosystem,
and we need to focus on a few key areas to do that.
One is we need to make it much easier to develop apps.
I have a lot of folks come to me with great ideas.
But the recommendation is always, get some funding,
find an app developer,
try to develop an app with that developer,
and then figure out how to maintain it.
We need to be able to make app development into
a much more commodity process so that good ideas are very rapidly translated.
We also need to increase the level of expectation that scientific findings,
particularly around those that
are designed to have an impact on the medical care process,
are computable and can be operationalized.
So I would really like to see publications that are developing algorithms,
have accompanying apps with them that can be
plugged into and tested in the health care system right away.
All right. Thank you, Mark. Very pleased to be here.